when the sun's out Surf's Up for
Dominique Heisner
he's been perfecting his tricks since he
was seven and that dedication has paid
off he's won the German championships
and finished fourth last year in the
wake skating World Cup
hi I'm Dominic sport is my greatest
passion I love being outdoors and in the
water and we have plenty of that in
Regensburg and the surrounding region
what he means is the Danube River and
it's tributaries a perfect backdrop for
all kinds of leisure activities this is
my first recommendation mountain biking
along the Danube you can spend hours
cycling along here the banks are
undeveloped and accessible almost
everywhere Reagan's book has a number of
cycle paths one takes you all the way to
Vienna Austria likewise on the Danube
with thrills spills and loads of hills
along the way
of course the coolest thing is riding
full speed down the country lanes
Dominic is partial to the roads less
traveled today he's taking us to the
Vince ahyes
which overlooked Reagan's book I always
end my tour here because it's where the
view of Reagan's walk is best the only
way to go from there is down his next
tip is in downtown Liggins for a couple
of blocks from the Cathedral the 12th
century stone bridge my second tip is
the yawn in zone it's really great for
barbecuing and hanging out the island is
an especially popular spot with young
people an oasis of green in the heart of
the city
now time to cool off
the Danube isn't really warm yet but
it's certainly refreshing if you have
the nerve Dominic's final recommendation
is the ultimate traditional [ __ ] fest
in Regensburg my third tip is the dote
as a Regensburg you have to come here at
least once the Bavarian Fun Fair is held
every May and September as it has been
for over 200 years the first thing to do
is get a liter of beer and meet friends
Regan's bogs population is only 140,000
at festival time it seems like the whole
town is here
and indeed the dort
typically attracts around a million
visitors in total making it one of the
biggest Fox fests in Bavaria
the best part is the ferris wheel with
its views of the entire city so long and
enjoy hope to see you again that same
wasn't work